Wow.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Oh,
what side?
Your whole life line six doc brown song.
Yeah,
but it's all wiped down and
has to take to this and that.
Their mom is wearing the crown
down or Rizzo wipe bomb bomb argon.
Seriously been shot or yeah,
and that's good at their job.
Lost their minds.
A 28 inch resign and man home.
Yes.
Quiet. Just borrowed it
was at the Yo man. All I
guess way it is, gets all told to
spread the knowledge about this shit.
Mommy see guests watching
clips and don't give a shit.
But I want to say this once street ball
does shout Ma'am mommy spending like,
fuck bro.
Y'All
are you kidding me? That's
classic. That's flown. So good.
We have the best music on the show.
We were in the car yesterday
listening to wrong submissions.
Yeah, it's ridiculous, man.
We just went through our podcast feed and
then played the opening songs and just
screamed out in the car yesterday so much.
One of the great musicians
listen to this show.
It's pretty nice. Yeah, we're always
impressed and we always love it.
So I'm always encouraging
anybody musically inclined to send
your instrumentals, send your,
uh,
your songs like this masterpiece
by plum. Um, it's just, uh,
it's so cool how that's, you
know, become part of the show.
Yeah. And it happened so
organically too. Yeah.
That's good.
It's good.
This reminds me of the Redondo
and we used to record there. Um,
so you want
to move, we should announced
this, first of all, first of all,
if there's a live your mom's
house podcasts coming up. My God,
my God,
it's part of the Burbank
seriously comedy festival.
There's laws law,
and it is Monday,
August 15th,
5:00 PM 5:00 PM we are doing
your mom's house podcast,
live in sperm bank at La
Paris comedy club. Uh,
get tickets now. That will definitely
fill up. Uh, it's gonna be really fun.
So make sure you check that out.
Jeans,
do you want to select some
other days? I do, yeah.
So I'm starting to tour again.
I'm doing one nighters starting
at in Seattle, Aka, wait.
Oh, I'm at the Te Comma to
come on your comedy club.
Clm Shut. Come me club. Wow.
Do you like that one? Yeah.
And then September 28th,
Portland or pork,
a man's whole helium comedy
club. I'm excited to do that
one. You like the helium,
all the helium's or, yeah. I've never
done helium. And then October 4th,
Dallas Phallus, hyenas, another good club.
Yeah. I fallen off the stage there
before. I hope I don't fall off this time.
October 5th, uh, huge dump Texas. Wow.
Houston and a nice play on
Houston. Yeah. Secret Group.
These are all submitted by listeners.
If secret group is a new venue, I think,
is that right? Yeah. It's a silly name.
I know. I worked with them as promoters,
so they were called the secret
group and I was say, okay. Right.
But then they opened a club
based on their promotional name.
It's called the [inaudible]. Like, Hey, do
you want to go down to the Cedar groups?
Yeah. Yeah. It's weird, but I, Hey,
I guess it works. It works. You know,
go to the secret group guys.
And then, um, all right.
This instrumental giving me
anxiety so it's too right. Intense.
Right? There's too much. Uh,
October 23rd, Indianapolis. Mommy,
Apolis mortise comedy club and
October 24th shit's a splatting.
That's really go bananas.
And then December 9th and
10th Matt the DC Improv.
That's it. That's great. And then usually
every Saturday at the comedy store,
Early Show and the o are seven
30 show. Come see me. Nice. Uh,
this week is your main
water guzzling champion.
The worst Cami buttons will
be in Timonium, Maryland.
Tim and good. Also just outside
of balls and horrors, Maryland.
Oh wait, I have another one for you.
Are you doing balls and horse? Yeah. Oh,
I'll wait until you get to that one
then. That's it right now. Oh, Baltimore.
Burt weighs more submitted
from listeners. Guys.
Bird weighs more Maryland. I'm
at [inaudible] House. What a name
this Thursday through Saturday.
Then the next weekend come
all over our bus, Ohio. Oh,
I've got another one for you.
Okay. Colin rust, colon rust. Wow.
Might have your upcoming.
Yeah.
And that is going to be August 11,
12 and 13.
That's a great club. I really do love
Columbus. It's great comedy. Clemis yes.
It's all like non binary to yes.
Then I'm a super non binary.
Then of course the live podcasts,
a string of dates with the odd ball tour,
which is a,
it's absurd. It's all amphitheaters
and arenas and shit. It's ridiculous.
And then after that nonsense,
like craziness ends,
I go back to reality
and I'm doing Charlotte,
North Carolina,
the comedy zone in October.
COBB's in a man friend, disco, California.
October,
2127 or 22nd and then
I'm going to Jude door,
kitties Carolines and also Louisville.
Hello.
What about liberal is what on me?
Email. Lose her. Lose her bill.
Loser. A loser. Her. Oh, Lou.
Looser her veil. Yeah. Yeah.
All right.
Goodness Jane fucking tell you guys.
We have a very exciting show.
Um, are you ready to do our
opening clip teens? Yeah.
Let me grab the baby g. All
right. It's unbelievable.
But we have baby jeans in studio
right now. Just woke up from his nap.
See if we can get him to make a noise.
He'll talk to you guys. Hold on.
A little distracted. Yeah, that
stuff just got up from his nap.
And I know a lot of you don't believe
that he exists, so baby jeans.
Say something to the audience.
Can you talk? Can you talk buddy?
What's up? Maybe if I annoy him, he'll
tie. You want to talk? You're gonna talk.
Come on buddy.
Say something.
Nothing. Now you're shy. They're not going
to say anything. Come on. Come on man.
We're, we're rolling. You got it. This
is your moment. No, no. All right. Well,
he's eight months old,
so he's just starting to make sense.
Maybe he'll talk once we started talking.
Yup. He's turning the mic from you.
He likes to grab thing. Yeah, he
grabbing, yeah. Oh, there we go.
Excellent. All right. You ready to
start the show and let's go. Let's go.
Who's fatter? Thompson or Bert
Kreischer. That's a very good question.
Very good question. I don't know if you
realize this, but to my very good friends,
Tom Sigora and Bert Kreischer,
they're both hilarious guys and they have
decided to do this thing where they're
calling each other fat. They're
both, but I love them both to jazz,
but they both lose a couple of pounds.
Think of bolts, lose a rural, um,
and they've just decided, uh, to, uh,
have this public thing where it's like,
Hashtag bird is fat.
Hashtag Thomas Fat, I'm going to
move my phone to this new thing. Ooh,
that's better.
Um,
and so they sell t shirts like half
Hashtag Thomas Fadden Hashtag birdies fat
tee shirts and all the proceeds from
the sales of those go directly to them.
So you're not helping
any fucking charities. No
starving. Kids are getting fed.
They're just going to
buy food and get fatter.
Oh, it's Ryan don't bring
in one loving to them.
Well, well, well go to your mom's house
Christina,
cause it's interesting.
Okay.
Yeah,
no man. Super good. Yeah, that was
hilarious. So I got baby jeans on my lab,
but grabbing a microphone,
he's looking around.
Maybe he'll talk. I Dunno. What, are you
going to talk? You can say something, Bro.
Ah, can we get, can we can't get like a,
well, he's not in the mood. He
just woke up maybe in a little bit.
He'll get chatty in a minute here.
That's hilarious. Joe Did a Joe
Rogan, our buddy did episode.
Um, eight, 27 of his podcast
where he just did a Q and.
A. That's how massive that guy's
show is. He can just be like Q and a,
so like three hours and then in
like, and probably get, you know,
whatever. 1 million downloads crazy. Um,
but people have been hitting him up
who's fatter because he's been so,
I haven't seen, I've been tagged
and tweets on, uh, on, you know,
on Twitter where they're, they're
tagging him. You're like, so Joe,
you haven't weighed in yet.
Who's fatter?
Did he, he didn't say whose
fatter, he just said you
both needed to lose some lbs.
Yeah. Yeah, he did. Yeah. And that you
guys are just going to buy it. Yeah.
You're going to buy more food.
Yeah, that's right. That's right.
What do you think Ellis?
Who's fat or your, yeah.
Oh, who's fatter? You're
going to weigh in on this?
Are you going to eat some microphone?
That's a cool thing that babies do.
We just put everything in there.
Yeah. Super Fun for Moms to
watch. Okay. Well anyways, uh,
very cool that he mentioned you
guys. Yeah. He madness. Yes,
he went on a little bit here. That's, it's
pretty funny. If you want to hear. Sure.
And birds case, he's probably going
to buy boxes of wine or drinks,
boxes of wine in an evening and so it
was trying to explain to me how many
bottles of wine that is and we don't
really know. I could Google that.
I'm going to Google that right now.
Let's find out. If you had to guess,
how many boxes of wine would you say
one box is? Probably, I mean two bottles.
All right. Let's take a quick, let's see.
I guess how many or how
many bottles are there?
How many bottles of wine or in
a box? All right. Eight bottles
of wine are in. Oh, no, wine.
I'm good. Before I click on it, I'm going
to say, I think, I think it was nine.
I'm going to say it seems
like a lot for bottles. Okay.
Okay. Wait, six, six and two
thirds bottles. All right.
Here it was 750 mil liter bottles.
How many?
750 milliliter bottles are there
in a five liter box of wine?
Well at six and two thirds.
And if it's a three liter box of wine,
it's four bottles.
Oh my God. But wine is so Bush League
Cup. Burt though, you know he's,
he's a machine. He starts
with cooking it up, man.
Yeah. That's an order, right?
I bet he's drinking the six
and two thirds in a night.
I think he's done more than one.
Yeah, I forget what he said. Yeah,
he's definitely drank at least one
box in a night on a regular basis.
So that's a four. Bob. I would be dead.
I don't know how he does it. Well he's,
he's definitely fat. I mean that helps.
And then it's also,
there's a helps
that helps. Uh, so he drinks
a box every night you think?
I don't think so. No. I
mean Bertrand also, he,
he moves it around like he
doesn't just stick to one style.
Like sometimes it's beer, sometimes
it's just funny. He was a beer guy.
He likes beer, he likes shots,
you know, he's a machine.
He's the part of you that no one
party is like bird. No one parties.
I have that first full weekend
of odd ball with him. Oh my God.
I'm going to have to like, oh my God,
no, my detox before and after. Oh my God.
Oh my God. And plus you guys are
going to get a lot of fat shaming,
shaming together.
We're going to get a lot of people can
be weighing in as you're performing.
Probably probably you're fat or we're
going to hear it's like thousands of
people and then also on the odd ball,
you know we,
him and I,
we're not the big dogs on the show.
So you do like a 15 minute set and then
you're, you're done. Right? So you got,
you have to drink is what
you're saying? I think, uh,
she just walked by all account.
Let me, we should, uh, can you,
can you pass them off real quick? Okay.
Yeah. Press printing. Press. All right.
So now baby jeans is back in his crate.
Yeah,
it's a family affair here and now we
have two dogs in here and we replaced the
dog with a tube to other babies. There's
always babies. No bubbles. Memphis.
Oh my God. The Mongan. Well,
what's really interesting about the bird
is fat phenomenon. And let's be honest,
there is no, Tom is fat
phenomenon. It is heavily weighted,
no pun intended, on Burt
Chrysler, Chrysler. Right.
And it is a phenomenon.
I mean if you look at the
Montreal comedy festival,
gave him his itinerary and it said burned
Chrysler Bark. Chrysler, Chrysler. Yeah.
Uh, we've been getting
countless tweets of Bev.
You wearing the shirts.
We've been getting international
submissions for Burdis fat. Yeah.
It's just taking, it's taking the world
by storm. Yeah, it's really great.
And I don't think it's,
I think it's just cause people love,
I don't know why this particular thing
to golf maybe cause it's just fun to,
to fat shame people as you know. Not
that that's bad. I think it's great. No,
I'm not maligning this. I think
this is a wonderful, yeah.
Public Service. We are describing
people in Latin. We're using adjectives.
Let's say the adjective or basis means,
uh,
let's try using that in a sentence.
So I'll put this on the
role of Bob's Christ
together.
Oh my God.
That was amazing.
There you go. That is beardo from
Australia. Thank you. Mom's Australia.
Australia. Yeah. That is wow. Leave. Wow.
That was amazing. Thank you for
doing that. See what I'm saying?
It's a worldwide phenomenon. Yeah.
Let's hope that it motivates Bert to,
uh,
to stop being so fat.
So undeniably unapologetically fat,
no remorse, right. No remorse
whatsoever. It's offensive.
I'm offended. Yeah. It's quite,
quite horrific to be in the presence
of should we call him by a new pronoun?
Like a fat brown?
I don't know man.
So that's an interesting way.
Maybe it needs a new pronoun. Thank you
for leaking like Lindsey. Thanks bets.
We have a quite a show lined
up for everybody. This is,
I'm not your typical mom show.
Um,
the genes machine and I,
we have a special family edition.
I mean you heard our
little son barely murmur,
but we also have my
sister LMG Maria was here.
Oh, okay. Um, I sat with here
with her and studio for a while,
talked to her.
I'm going to get into that and then I
have almost a full hour of top dog and
Charo. Oh my God. I'm
going to start things off.
Why don't we get, uh, the
Maria portion. Oh my God.
Your sister when she was here was on all
cylinders. Yeah. Do you realize what she,
she flew across the country was a
one year old. It's unbelievable.
And on two connecting flights.
Yeah.
And then showed up here and the baby
was exhausted and she just, it just,
it just rolls off her back.
Like I envy that level of like,
I don't care what to let, let's go.
And I think we need to interrupt.
One thing we didn't think about is how
much our show luckily has grown since the
early days for people that are joining
us that maybe had to listening for a
month or so and they're like,
what's the big deal?
The foundation of this show
in a lot of ways is OMG Maria.
In the old days,
man,
we would get her on the phone and she
would just be fired up about some lcs or d
sees. Those are lazy concen dumb cons.
Starbucks fucking up her Starbucks order.
I'd never thought that Maria was
stopped drinking coffee, but she did.
I know it's an, it's a bummer
for our show, which I know
I want to encourage her.
I don't care about her health. I want the,
the content. I know she drinks tea now,
which just does not as fun as that is fun.
And she's not as angry as she used
to be at Starbucks. The caffeine,
she would order like three or four drinks
per day and that would make her angry
or naturally fired up.
So it's fucking amazing.
It's like the caffeine was
throwing kerosene on her
personality. It was perfect.
Um, so anyways, I want to play for you,
the Maria conversation and a,
then we'll come back and we'll talk
and we'll get you into the top dog and,
and Charles Conversation.
Yeah, I can't wait to hear
this. Alright, here we go guys.
Oh Em.
Gee Maria.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my
God. Oh my God. Seriously.
Seriously. Seriously.
Seriously. Oh my God.
Oh my God.
You're fucking McGee.
Hand seriously as the backup and
had a hole in it is important.
That goddamn bottle. Oh my God. Seriously
female. Okay. All these
bodily fluids come out.
Do you think there's more coming at you
is too there was semen or something,
something else? Semen would be from
three days ago. Yeah. You know,
I got pregnant with Weston five days
after we had sex and there was still,
usually when we have sex,
it still leaks out of me for like a few
days after because apparently I have a
very mucusy cervix. Hmm. How do you,
how do you find out something like that?
The doctor told me because when we
estimated the date of conception was in
California and Shabbos in Chicago, I'm
like, I had sex with them a week ago.
Is that unusual?
I don't really know.
I mean I think usually if it happens
within two or three days because they die
out.
I don't know exactly how it happens,
but apparently with his strong swimmers
and my super mucusy cervix just hangs
out in there. So like five days
later it's just leaking out. Whoa.
That's why I can't wear thongs
usually. Yeah, we can't, you know,
I had to wear underwear with
like something there for
like the week after we got
after sex. Yeah. He like comes in
me or I can't have a massage. Like
you know if we have sex
that day for a few days,
cause it's happened once before where
I was having like a massage and it was
like, it was like gross and like a
snail trail after I got from the,
it was so disgusting. I know. It's
so brown. Yeah. Lesbians do it.
Like knowing what the shit comes out of
your bodies. I don't get at, wait, wait.
You don't understand what
was going to do what?
Like knowing what comes out of your body,
how they like go downtown on each other.
Oh yeah.
Really? Yeah. I know. I mean when I,
knowing what comes out of me and
the worst part is as you get older,
it's stinkier kids.
When you see like older lesbian and
you're like I can't, I don't know. Yeah,
I don't understand it. I'm like, it's so
gross down there. Cause you feel gross.
I feel disgusting. Yeah.
I think it's disgusting.
Like the vagina as you
get older is disgusting,
especially of you have
kids and it's just gross.
Everything about it's disgusting.
Hairy balls and saggy vault.
It's actually the same argument can
be made when you think about it.
What you're saying applies to a straight
man with a woman as they get older
because that's also an
older vagina at time. No,
but I mean it's the same. The same thing.
They have to comply. It's up to him.
Him lapping it up every night
or whatever. Yeah. You know,
it's discussing.
What about Old Dick?
So they get saggy. And I haven't
been that. I'd never say no.
I haven't been with a really old deck,
really know. And Jeff is younger,
so I've been with, um,
well I've been with,
but I've seen my dad's balls.
Is it so discussing and I have seen on
videos like old saggy and they're so
Wrigley's balls. I'm not even kidding
actually. It's been a while now,
but I've been in the, in their bedroom
where he, you know, he changed,
so he drops his,
his underwear down and bends and
like it looked like animal testicles,
like did that big and they
hang were enormous. God,
like go to pick nuts. Yeah. Yeah.
And I was like, Whoa, dad. He
goes, well, what are you doing?
And he just started to see samples,
man, looking at your balls.
I'm going to talk to him about his
balls. If I see that video, that nut bra,
the Nub Brown. Yeah. They did a little
comedy thing about, cause you know,
old men as they would go to the bathroom,
cause their ball start to drop and
sag and they would drop in the toilet.
Said someone came up with like an up
raw, it was a joke. But now you know,
you don't sit on your balls anymore
and you don't have to worry about them
dropping in the toilet. It was
really funny. And there's that. Um,
there's the story about, you know, Mr
Belvedere remember that show? Yeah.
That he sat on his nuts,
um,
at a read through and it's off bad
to delay shooting an episode once.
Yeah. She sat on his testicles.
That sounds awful. I know,
I know. So gross. I've actually heard
they getting kicked in the nuts.
They coolant and pain from man,
like getting kicked hard is the
equivalent of pain as like, you know,
labor contractions. But the only thing is
labor contractions go on and on and on.
It's so horrible. Yeah. It hasn't
happened obviously in years, but he did a,
he measured pain.
Like they actually like that measured
pain receptors on a man and it kicked him
in the nuts. Oh my God. I mean the idiot
that was willing to do this is amazing.
But um, and then they did
it, you know, women, the pain
receptors. It's weird thing.
I've never,
I mean I'm,
I'm really all about whatever get
whatever turns you on is, you know,
do your thing.
But there's a whole whole segment of,
you know,
adult erotica that's about dudes
getting kicked in the balls.
Yeah, yeah. I love it. Yeah.
They love it. Oh my God. There's
some sick people, you know,
I think I can understand that guys
signing up for it and they get kicked him
fucking hard, hard, and
repeatedly, not once.
And sometimes they cough up and they
have blood coming out of their dicks.
Oh my God. Yeah. I mean,
they signed up for it.
I thought porn ones when a guy had like a,
like a long metal tubing shoved.
Oh my God. Oh my God. That
his penis. I just don't get
it. The pain thing. No, that,
that thing, I definitely don't
get her right neck. Yeah. Well,
so it's eating stool and like
shitting on each other. Nobody,
there's something seriously wrong with
these people. Yes. I totally agree.
And I want to know what goes through
their head that they think like this is
normal. I'm definitely going to find a
great woman that wants to do this with me.
She's quality material.
It's, I know. So, um,
I think I've ever had you have ever had
you in studio? I did once before, right?
Yeah. And uh, Redondo.
So obviously people are
a big fan of yours. Um,
there, everyone's always been surprised
that you stopped drinking Starbucks,
but where do you encounter,
um,
your LLCs and dcs these days?
Cause that was like the main
place used to get them a voice.
You're now living in Florida. He
find a surprising number of them. Um,
well one the worst.
I think the greatest population
of lcs and dcs would be at Kmart.
I went once,
I will never return.
The second group is definitely Walmart.
Unfortunately I have to go
there every now and then.
Sam Clubs is the Fattest Group of
lcs and dcs. Really? It's horrible.
I actually at the point now that on
the weekends I refused to go to Publix.
Sam's club or Walmart or any grocery
shopping, I can't deal with it anymore.
I think goes out there. And how
disgusting and how obnoxious and rude.
So Sam's Club, you know, you
go, we go on the weekend,
we did our bulk shopping of stuff and
it's all have also happens to be sampled
day. So every aisle has samples.
And you had these heifers,
I mean these huge families and they
bring the whole fucking family.
I mean it's not like mom or dad doing
the groceries. It is mom, dad, brother,
sister, grandma, the wheelchairs.
They've got the automated wheelchairs
everywhere and they just stop and they
just go on these feeding frenzies it's
like going on a carnival cruise with all
you can eat buffet.
It's disgusting.
And you and I just want to go get a
fucking rotisserie chicken and some toilet
paper, but you can't get through the
aisle and I lose my shit so I can't,
I told you, I'm like, it makes
me angry. And it was my weekend.
Like I just want to go buy some things
and go home and I can't go through
anywhere. So you're really angry when
you see like a super obese people? No,
I don't get angry.
I want to see obese people.
I get angry when they make the whole,
they feel like I'm inconveniencing.
They're feeding frenzy and they
just, you know, they're in,
they're in my way of everything. We're
getting animals. They were like animals.
Yeah. And it's like my fault.
Like they're like, excuse me,
I'm trying to eat a sample here and as
long as well as the rest of the store and
you just see like what they're doing.
Like I just, I don't understand. Like,
if you're at the point where you
can't see your genitals or your feet,
why do you think it's okay to go get
like mass quantities of like pork,
ribs and Cheetos and it's disgusting.
And you just,
I remember when we were
in these obviously, but we
were in high school. Yeah.
There was a pretty big kid of
the other high school. Okay.
And um,
one of my friends told me there
was good friends with him,
but one of my friends who was good
friends with him and told me that, uh,
his family made every meal with Bacon
and that they've saved the bacon grease
and that they would use the big ruse
to like co can flavor things with.
I'd never heard of that
since then or before then.
I did that with duck fat.
Really? Yeah. When I cooked doc,
I say the grease and I'll use it to
like saute potatoes or vegetables.
You see the George multiple jars.
It's disgusting.
I mean I would say one darn
it would last me forever.
Every meal is or their bacon sausage
some. They were big people too. Yeah.
But then there comes a point where
we're like, you know what, this law,
you look at everyone else around you
and you're like, something's wrong.
I can't see my feet. I should probably
do something about it. I think those are,
yeah,
that is the way I think the,
what happens with when their families
have those epidemics is that you've made
it normal at your home.
So on your feed,
your kids and you take your kids to go
give them sugary drinks and a bunch of
crap and garbage and that's all they
know. It's the norm for them. Yeah.
It's the same thing with like all
those teenage moms that you know these,
so when I was doing that,
the class is at the women's care
center and I would have these girls,
I mean they're girls like
in high school coming in,
they're on their third or fourth
pregnancy and they had no interest in ever
doing anything. They're like, oh, just
get on WIC and food stamps and welfare.
Yeah. And, and it's normal. Like
this is what the norm is to them.
There's a zero dream or aspirations
to do anything more with your life.
It's depressing. Yeah.
No, I gotta say you, um,
you have this unreal drive to work out.
Yes. It's so cool. Where do you
think that comes from? Where you are,
where you work out?
So savagely to get my aggression out
and eat a healthy outlet. It's really,
yeah.
I mean I need to do something to get my
frustrations out and energy and board of
the frustrations come from
using everybody's frustration
to me now. You know,
like working kids, it's exhausting.
So it's good to be like that.
Like life in general.
Yeah.
I mean like when things piss you
off and if you didn't do that,
it would just be like, you have been
irritable bitch. I be intolerable. Really?
Yeah. I mean you see now as the poor, like
even in high school, like if something,
if I get mad, I mean frustrated.
I need you just our families,
the St will explode if I don't find
some way to get it out. Yeah, true.
I feel the, I feel a similar. Yeah. I mean
I need somewhere to explode. I can just,
I can be aggressive. I'm not
hurting anybody. I need, I have,
we all have aggressive jeans.
I need somewhere to get that out.
That's not going to harm others.
I mean, useful for people to know.
You flew from the east coast, you
connected in Dallas, you had to lose,
you got here in the evening and nine,
it wasn't like we went to bed relatively
late and then you got up really early
case got up so early and then when I
got up you'd run five miles and uh,
most of it is at an incline,
a severe incline. I was,
I was not prepared for that one. Pushing
that stroller up that hill was like God.
But I was explaining to me what you
did. First of all, I have yet to see,
I don't want to give away my address,
but in this neighborhood,
I've yet to see anybody run where you
were running. I mean, that's a walk,
you know,
and most people walk up that slowly.
This is crazy that you were able to run
five miles and that you did it at seven
in the morning. No, I did
it, I think at nine. Nine.
I don't think so. Maybe eight,
maybe eight I think. I have no idea.
It was up so early. I just didn't know. I
just needed to get her calm. I was like,
okay, here we go. So after that run,
you feel totally like more balanced?
I do. I was telling me my legs are
shot and afterwards I was tired,
but I felt really calm the
rest of the day. I was super
chill. And then like
today, what will you do?
You and I are going to do
a burpee circuit. I burpee
challenge burpees, challenge.
You're going to do it. Preppy
challenge, 30 minutes nonstop, nonstop,
or every channel.
ABS dips in between.
Okay, cool. It'll be, it'll be,
it'll feel good after tired. Look good.
Um, and then you're really on top of,
you love to cook, but you
like healthy cooking. I do
like how they cooking. I mean,
I don't want to be, you
know, a Walrus. Yeah,
I see enough of them at Walmart and
Sam's Club. Yeah. So rose, that's okay.
Do you think bird, his hat? Who? Bert?
Bert Chrysler.
Just kidding. He's a
friend of mine. Oh, okay.
There you go. Genes. There is what
wasn't there in that interview. I've,
I feel like you guys covered it
all. She, she hates fat people.
She hates vaginal discharge.
She hates old balls. Yeah.
And Publix. Walmart. I mean
that was, I was amazed.
It was amazing.
She's evolving and I her by the way,
you're right that that level of fitness
she had when she came to visit us was
like,
remember that one time in Miami when
before we took the family cruise and she
flew in on a red eye. Yeah. And was that
the night we were like, we're going to,
we'll meet you for breakfast. I did. Well
I did because I was also international.
I was coming, I came over
from Asia I think. Right.
So I was waking up every day
at like four in the morning.
So I was like, dude, I'm out at earliest
shit breakfast. And she was like,
have meet you at that place.
So she meets me there and she's
in full workout gear and I'm like,
that's what time is it? It's like six in
the morning, six in the morning. And I go,
uh, we're going to breakfast. And she was
like, I'm just gonna have a glass of tea.
And they went, do you said you meet
me for breakfast? I know, I know.
I'll sit with you. What are you
going to do? I'm going to run.
And then she ran like seven Myers
and she was like, I fell it hard.
One in Miami. It's not, it's never
not hot and humid. Yeah. That's great.
Summertime in Miami. Yeah. It's crazy.
It's crazy. Lunatic. Yeah, man. Wow.
She really hates what comes out of her
vagina. I wonder what's happening. Yeah,
I liked it. I mean, she uh, likened
that to a lesbian problem. Right.
As opposed to all the older heterosexual
couples and where there's also one
vagina and that there might
be an issue for the man or,
or like old stinky dicks
and balls are not a problem.
Yeah. There's nothing like Mario
fired up, man. I just want to go,
I just want to get a rotisserie
chicken on my paper. I'm,
I told pepper and I can't
cause that people eating
like can I gusting or your hair?
Yes.
Hobert Rawer Cordova [inaudible] over
Crawshaw you are a fat can't, uh, you're
a fat. They can't then Tom Segura might.
Wow. That's international. That was
amazing. That was British Irish.
Um, Polish. Yeah. Let's
see. There was Ireland,
Poland and mom's Australia and
other moms. Wow. Pretty Great.
Why
Cobart Cordova love sugar,
but Christ Crawshaw
you are a fat can't, uh,
they can't. [inaudible]
oh my God. Shit. That's a really good,
um,
now genes for the mother load.
This is a top dog and Charo in studio.
Oh my God,
I can't wait to hear this.
We've been talking about that by the way.
Charro sat in blue bands chair and I had
to constantly just like point to talk.
Like you will hear her like this and
she's like, yeah, and then what are you?
And I'm like, mom. And I actually
got to the point where you know, you,
you have ways you navigate parents.
I was like,
I don't want even want
to correct her anymore,
but I just let her talk
off my head just to not,
you know, bother, you know what
I mean? Like, just let it go.
I have it in Hungarian.
Do you want to hear Wiseberg Chrysler.
Chrysler's a bad mayor.
Bert Kreischer on Euro Qvr.
That's really good.
Myth myth.
Medved Kreischer Anurag cover.
Yeah.
On Europe go. They're nicer, EH,
bad crisis.
Um, anyways, it was such a
pleasure to have them in here.
There's a lot man. We get into
so many things. We got it.
We get into nonbinary or we
get into the gender pronouns.
We get into king ash Reber who get into,
um,
I think I convinced them how silly their
worry of a transsexual is using the
wrong restroom or like, you know,
the restroom they desire. Right.
I think I talked to him off
the ledge on that one. Uh,
play songs that they're in,
that listeners have made. It's,
um, it's a lot of fun.
So I wait to hear this.
Without further ado.
My mother Charro and my father.
Who many of you adore top dog
here in the studio right now?
Hey Buddy. Stop Dog. Kate, buddy.
Stop Dog.
Okay Buddy.
You need to
stop dog
picture which picture in
front of me? Oh, of us? Yeah.
Are you talking? All right. Good. Yep. Um,
everything's going wrong today.
So annoying.
I'm ready. Ready for what? Whenever
you start, we already started. Oh,
we did? Oh yeah. Okay. We'll take
hello? No, what do you mean? Hello?
Hey. Hey. Can I talk about your
house? What do you wanna talk about?
But first I want to talk
about the baby and for what?
Cause I want to steal the baby. And
it's important that you know it. Oh,
you can steal them. That is to die for.
Yeah. I am obsessed with their baby.
It reminds me of me. That
cute. Well, what? I want it,
I want to talk quickly. Finish. Go ahead.
He's Barry Lynn billion.
Extremely observant coaches and yes,
it complete joy. Yeah. No,
well it's a guy from there.
I come in the house. The house is
beautiful, but I need to go to a bathroom.
Yeah. Tommy [inaudible] it's
going to cause a divorce.
You're fired if he doesn't get me that
toilet, you want it, right? No. Yeah,
we've talked about it a bunch that uh,
it's really a game changer.
It really is just, you know what number
one, even if I'm cold, my whole body,
I go to the bathroom,
I sit there and it is so warm that depict
honestly your war map, my whole body,
it has an environmental advantage because
you actually use less toilet paper.
Yeah. And you know, so
you're really actually,
but then you're using a lot of water,
I guess is kind of a tradeoff.
Well know it takes more water
to make that amount of time,
so I think it's a better deal. Yeah.
Well I know that I feel a lot cleaner.
It does that well. When I,
when I first did my yesterday,
when I did my first dump here. Yeah.
And then I went in for my normal rewind.
A lot of times when I do adopt,
but I have a wipe and then
they have to go back a little.
But all that you know about whole ledge?
Yeah. Where they would get at a
hotel. He barely made it to the room.
Oh, that was mid day. He went from there
to the shower. I didn't really know.
It was a classic.
It really was a 3.5 it
wasn't quite a four.
It was so bad that he told me he won't
tell me about it too. Don't discuss,
tell me about it. It went,
it went on for like ever.
It was one wasn't a last year was a
three, five, probably three, eight,
maybe one to four and it
just kept going out out now.
So it was kind of solid. Well it was, it
was, there was a softness to it. Okay.
So it was so maybe closer to
4.0 yeah. Yeah. Okay. From
the bedroom.
I wasn't sure if he was making
movies or he was doing pub
anyway. It was like it was
gigantic. Okay. And then,
but here's what happened.
It kind of,
the last bit kind of broke off so I
didn't have enough in me to shoot out the
last bit. So some of it kind of
hung there. So I had to go through,
had to go through half a roll of toilet
paper to get the last bit out and it was
just dirty.
So finally what I had to do is get up
and get in the shower and finish off in
the shower. So you went shit the
shower. Oh, immediately. Yeah. Yes.
Now do you ever take a shit and then go
to the shower without wiping even once?
Oh No, I never do that. No.
What I do is I make an
evaluation businessman's or
seen it does that I make an
evaluation if I'm, if I'm, if I'm a
half a roll of toilet paper in. Yeah.
And it's still some there. I've got to go
to shark. Oh. But the thing is that, that,
that big day kind of saves you now that
you think will meet men you think has
made me, I want to make it, I know this,
this trip is going to cost me some
money to cause I, when we get back,
here's what we have to do.
We have to, she'll go online.
I don't know if Amazon prime sells these
things or not, but she'll find out.
The company's called
Toto USA. Toto USA. Okay.
I dunno because we rent this house so,
okay.
You're going to have to go to total
USA and look into that and have, uh,
now you have to pick out your favorite,
your re replaced to do it too.
You just can't have it. I mean
we can't, okay. The melon,
it's actually called a,
they call it a washlet I
think is what they call it.
Divide it down for me because
it's got the heated toilet seats.
Got a heated toilet seat
too. It's great. Yeah.
I enjoyed that when I tested
it out yesterday, you know?
Yeah. It's called a washlet.
Honestly getting my job.
But you walk out of that place.
I do took a shower.
It's pretty amazing because people in
basically take showers for main parts of
your body to be clean.
Yeah.
And that's the most important part of
your body and when you get out of there
and said, oh my gosh, I feel
like just, it's incredible.
It is.
I can't believe that I'm going to be 69
years old next month and I never used
one of those things until yesterday.
It's incredible.
You think about what I'd been missing
out or you really have been missing out.
I know. I feel like my life's
changed ever since. Ever since
girls have these things I went to,
it's gonna be ridiculous. Your
factories, your mother. Yeah.
I mean I haven't seen a smile on
her face like that and then a while.
Let me tell you just teasing. Just
teasing. Okay. Now have you had any
double pipe classics and all
recently double double pipe classics?
I have no idea about.
It's like when you fart and Burp at
the same time. Those are very rare.
Only lately, but never. Thank God
I am Numb. He's had them. I've had
it.
Not often,
but there it depends where you hear that
you have the capacity of doing it from
the top and the bottom at the same
time. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's not,
it's not very common. It's both barrels.
Yeah, it's, it's, yeah, it's both girls.
Absolutely disgusting. But think
about is it that one? Yes and no.
You never had one about three weeks ago,
but what, what did you eat to be able to,
I think it was having Sushi
and something carbonated,
but the cool part is usually the gas picks
one hole and in this case it went out
of both at the same time. So I
farted and burp together. I, yeah,
it's very rare people can do that.
It's not very common sticks an effort.
Well it has to do, I think of it
more like magic because you can't,
you can't fake it. You
can't fake it. You can't,
I mean it went from the baton just
comes out. It just came out. Yeah.
As you are doing the effort to go.
I think actually the effort,
I was going to fart and it went
out of my mouth at the same time,
like I wasn't expecting the Burkhart
top of that. You were proud of that?
I made tee shirts about
it. You called me. Yeah.
He called me immediately and we make it
for us. I'm doing this and you can't.
You can't. No, no, you can. You, you have
to go back and reminisce. It had been,
I think I said to have been a few years
since I had one of those. Yeah. You know,
it's like, it's like Haley's
comet only comes. Exactly. Yeah.
Everybody comes every so often,
but well people,
people have been messaging me after
I talk about it and saying, you know,
does it count when I sneezed and Fart?
And I go,
absolutely not because that's a natural
pressure thing to sneeze and push out a
Fart, but to burp and Fart is,
it's pretty special. Yeah. That,
that is a topic of conversation
and know there's a bunch of topics.
There's this guy,
he goes by a king ass ripper.
He's called the Fart. God,
I wanted to show you him.
I think this is simply the same topic.
He's called the part guy here,
but watch him.
He makes his videos.
Yeah.
Found him and we gave
him a lot of publicity.
Yeah.
Yeah. Isn't that incredible? He's been
doing these for years now. Yep. So yeah,
but look how good he is.
Okay.
It looks like me a
little, right? Yeah. Oh,
it's real. Real. Yeah. I met a
guy in college that good, good.
Breathe air and breathe
air in and blow it out. Yet
I do it just like that.
This guy has
not as good as this guy.
No, this guy's good.
This guy's a 70 yard. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He also has different videos.
I don't want to say that.
Listen to that and say, whoa. Yeah.
I wonder if you could write music to that.
You'd like notes for that people have
taken his far as amazing songs that I can
say that.
Yes.
Which is
hours, video hours. How does he manage
to get done when its roots? I don't know.
That's a great question,
Huh?
Right.
You think so?
Do you think that's why he goes,
nobody can work. I've
seen it. I've seen it.
No one guy, he's said nowadays and
faking it. I make people believe it.
Let's see. So it sounds like a perfect.
Okay. You guys speak more into the mic.
Okay.
Yup.
Like this.
Oh
yeah. Yeah. Look, look at
that medical part like this.
No, he's really doing work.
Look how dirty those panties or
underwear.
So dirty.
Oh
No, look at his stomach. It's
all good. It's all gas. Yeah.
Oh No,
no.
You got a sunset sunset.
Well that is a real sunset.
Okay. Okay. Well, just to show
you how great this guy is.
Absolutely. He does. Uh Oh God. And know
don't do this. You can see his face.
He does like
he does. I'm glutton scenes too.
You know, like we're, he'll eat,
he'll just eat, eat, eat, eat, eat, eat,
eat and then burp
living. Yeah, I think so.
I think he has people that pay
him to do it. I mean, yeah.
Tell me what's that got to make
that business zone. Now. I can't,
I can't get on a die.
You're wanting to get into that.
You can't control it like that. Mine
just, mine is always spontaneous.
Spur of the moment. Yeah, don't
work. You had to. It is now.
Now if you try to do it, you can't
do it. It's gotta be natural.
It's a natural thing. Yeah. This guy,
he just has these videos all over the
internet, but I have to have bacon.
I tell me discussing when talks to them
just barely ripping or Rhonchi far farts
are my, ah, Ooh, I should
have some more Berlin.
I kept it off. This is
disgusting. It's pretty cool.
We judge something.
Went back to park.
Okay,
so you know that your
daughter Maria was in here.
She's a,
she's very well liked by the listeners.
So we had had them email
questions and Maria answer them.
Yes, that'd be classy. Okay. You
can hear it. I'm really, you know,
you're very popular on the show.
People really like getting to know you
and I want to get to know you a little
better.
I've had some questions submitted
from fans and some of them are,
you know, in an appropriate, but
that's kind of the theme of the show.
So I'll just start with this
and you just let me know if I'm,
you know what the answer
is. Okay. Okay. Um,
what's the most amount of guys
you've had sex with in one day?
One day?
Yeah.
I'd say for what,
but neither of us climax one,
if that counts all four times.
Four different guys. Well,
three different guys. I climb, I sweat
the fourth one. Neither of us did,
so I don't, that counts. So
food, that's a crazy number nine.
If you'd think about it over the course
of 24 hours and it was spring break,
you gotta be kidding, right? Yeah.
Spring break. We're talking 20 here.
Four. I mean, all her stories
are crazy. You know, of course.
I didn't know what that was.
I mean that she's always
pushed the envelope,
but then realize that this
was FedEx. Okay. Yeah, I mean,
mine
for, uh, she, uh,
I think on the fourth one because he
was almost a climax. They didn't climax.
Yeah. But this was back in her crazy
days, guys, four different guys.
I need you to do the roof of a hotel.
One time she told me you're kidding up.
So we were there. Then I remember we were
in a hotel that she went to the roof.
Yeah, because they had to pull the
pull this closer. Where was that?
I am trying to remember. We
were there again, was there,
told me was that it was still,
they keep hiring them.
Idea says I'm going
upstairs to lay in the pool.
Took her forever to come back and
that could be it. That could be, yeah.
She says she has so much time.
You don't mind is crazy.
Spring break and you were these just
random guys you would just run into,
but they were there all week
at the same place. Holy Shit.
That means that I understand
the translation. If she,
if they're there then more than 24 hours,
it deletes the word random. Right? Yeah.
I mean that's, that's good. Okay. Yeah,
so there was one of them, I don't know,
but there's a three I'd seen around,
so that's what, that's
ridiculous. That's a lot. No,
a blind
one of them.
One of them,
I didn't know three of them I'd seen
around seem I've round, I see them around.
So like if she saw him mouth to have,
so basically what you're saying is,
so have you seen with him
because he didn't even know,
they didn't even know his
name. That's good. Yeah.
I mean if I walk around and I pick it up,
she didn't get paid.
So technically speaking it's not. So
what is it calling? It isn't being loose.
Oh it seems like a lot back then. I did
not. Did you do that again somewhere else?
No, the most I ever did
after that was to one night.
Wow. That's a lot. All
right. Question number two.
What's the most cocaine you've
ever done in a day? Oh my God.
I think three grams.
Three grams. But give a,
cause you know what three grams are but
either July. So that's why a non user,
an idea of what that is. Like what,
what does, what does three grams mean
strictly on the scene and
you would use cocaine.
You generally do like
align. Align is like, yeah,
so that's one line,
right?
Just like a fraction of a gram
side maybe did like 30 40 lines,
30 or 40 lines of coke and
one day while in Mexico,
Mexico, Mexico, which is
so dangerous. Oh my God.
So she was she,
she helped start a drug cartel basically.
Business. Yeah. It's good to know. Yeah.
This is the most scariest
thing I've ever heard
from a guy that was our waiter who happens
to also be a drug dealer and as well
as the guide on our fishing trip,
I don't know,
few years ago
in tango. Wow. Really? She remembers.
That's really dangerous.
Yes.
Remember that guy she has to
remember is the drug dealers.
She just hit them. Yes, I do. No,
I don't think you did because you
were making fun of this. Well,
I mean it is prostitution then.
He's a drug dealer.
That's what it is. I mean 30
grams of the rocks. Your daughter,
cocaine anymore. No, I mean there's
this, that was all in the past.
That makes it, okay, well it's over. What
do you want to do it? It's in the past.
It's still the brain is damaged.
I realize that that leaves
the next question here. Um,
have you ever been
arrested and taken to jail?
Uh, and if so, what for?
You have gone to jail?
I have gone to jail. Mom and dad do
not. Where, what city were you in?
I was in,
I was in Chicago.
You got arrested and taken to jail?
Jeff and I were living
together and decent behavior.
We were high and drunk and naked
running around the streets in the snow.
I'm challenging each other.
Her neighbors called police.
How'd you ally? Cause obviously you
don't think you got charged right now.
Jeff had a lawyer. Thankfully that's
grandparents bailed us out of that one.
Really? Yeah. How long were you in
jail? Just few hours. Few Hours.
Sounds plausible to me.
They were naked in the streets.
There were,
but this is a heavy drug use these days.
It doesn't feel good to him.
He just goes,
gets the drunk naked and
go outside to do stuff.
Well people, people on drugs do
crazy things. It's not that unusual.
I mean they do.
Yeah. This is the most escape.
Interviewer you ever heard in my life?
I can't believe we're
talking about my daughter.
She parties pretty hard.
You know,
I didn't know that. I knew she
party and have fun and you should.
I mean, I remember one time, it
really affect me. We were in church,
I mean out of all the places media
decide to tell me riding mass.
She didn't around.
She says,
I want you to know that they already had
sex before she was in high school and
that is okay.
I don't have a baby and brain in mass
with my kids and husband and didn't
realize it. I don't want to lie.
So it's important for you to know.
It's an interesting
spot to a nice clean up.
I think he's a smart spot to come clean.
I couldn't even talk. I just keep going.
And that's you're right. Yeah.
And after mass I said, Maria,
you shocked me in the middle of the night.
She says what?
It bothers me that you didn't know.
And I said,
when you're a kid and you
said there is no baby.
And she said, no, you don't
have to worry for that part.
So I never wanted to ask why?
Because I don't know if she, yeah,
things happen. And the guy is
not a boyfriend. He was, yes.
I don't mind. It was one of the
five guys that she had in one day,
but here there's more.
It's pretty intense.
Um,
have you ever committed a robbery?
Yeah, big ones. Small ones.
It's more of what I think she confused.
Robbery was shoplifting though.
Things have you prob tic tacs,
lot of alcohol and cigarettes.
That's like shoplifting clothes.
I mean,
but have you ever broken into somewhere
and stolen? Yeah, I was really,
I don't even remember what we stole it.
We were like stupid and drunk and
we just went into someone's house and
took stuff and just someone's house.
That's crazy. And what city was
that? That was in Boston. Really.
So college days,
not the easiest. Really Sad. Wow. This is
absolutely the place to hear my daughter.
No,
it's a colorful past.
A colorful pass to be roasted
to drug dealers. Going to jail.
It means you've lived a full
life. It free lights. Yeah.
That's not the way to beat the light.
I think I prefer,
I prefer to think of her as is a a what
a great mother and she is today and then
I just, it's eccentric. She's eccentric,
she's a century. But you know,
I guess as a father, you know, I realize
that people do things in the past,
but I think I,
this is like,
well, I have to tell has
been peace palace. Yeah. It's
okay. It's in the person.
Wonderful human being. Yeah. At
least I hope that she never, ever,
ever judge anybody. Right. Yeah.
That's a good point. Good point.
Yeah. That's a good college.
That's amazing. It's a good
point. I didn't know that.
I mean, I, you know, still there's
so many things that were blurry.
They give us kind of like,
yeah, I think I did the,
I don't remember the specifics about
it, but I remember, can you kind of,
it's kind of a haze. Yeah. I remember
we were really drunk and they were out.
We knew that the people were the God
and the brownstones on Brookline.
And so we've just kind of went on.
I don't be, didn't take anything.
We just kind of hung out in their house
and paint your alcohol and eat their
food. And then like, okay,
I'm gonna go back. Wow.
I ever been in a fight with weapons.
Hm. I think that, I remember the,
the boss university tuition was 19,000
a year in those days. So I'm glad. Yeah.
My money was,
was going for good cause good cause for
19,000 it was tuition that didn't it no
weapon Roman board. Well, there's
something about that here.
Yeah.
No, I really wanted to though. I've always
wanted to be like, like a warrior tasks.
I'm like fight someone and just win.
Yeah. I haven't had that opportunity.
Words and stuff. Yeah. I
think that's kind of the,
one of the reasons why I joined the navy.
I was thinking I was going to get to
go and do some kind of like mission
impossible, you know, stuff. And I did it.
I even took martial arts
classes and it didn't happen.
How about, um, have you ever done anything
in the adult film industry? Like porn?
I did a long, long time ago
because I needed extra money.
I didn't feel dad was giving me a math
in college and who is really excited that
finally I will start asking for money
and my credit card expenses went down,
which he doesn't know is that
I did do one film for cash.
Hi. This is Debbie. This is a
job. No, no, this is not real.
Yeah, that's good. That's
Marie exaggerated. It's got to
be, I don't think so. No. I,
I can't imagine her doing that.
Really. I know that's gotta be here
in college. I got like, like, like $2,500
I am dealing with, I
think, I'm going to think,
I just, I think sometimes Maria, yeah,
go ahead Maria.
She is very good at in Bella Sheen
and playing to the role. Yeah.
I mean, I, I really, that one, I
don't, I just don't believe it.
Here's another,
just one more.
Yeah.
So had this idea that um,
it's mom and dad are coming.
I want to play this game where
they're always like, oh my God, Maria.
So Maria shocks this way.
Surprises this. Yeah, so
they're always like in
disbelief of your reality.
So I thought it would be fun, but I
was saying it right now and I'll, I'll,
I'll play this later. Okay. I'm
asking you to make things up,
but the game will be that this is real.
Yes.
And it'll be something like this.
Like I'll say,
why did we get played? I mean
you're talking about hook,
line and sinker being played.
No, no, no. I was calling my tears because
I was in the worst really effect. Really?
Oh I'm sorry.
Did they went to jail?
But that's pretty good
amps and he scared buddies.
Took him Outta jail guys. For Times.
It's sitting years, a walk around.
The God is stole from everybody,
but we should have it knowing
Mariana says for exaggeration,
I started to get suspicious for me at
one point I said to me a little bit,
it's going to be real that he, she
did it, but I think I believe it.
Tommy is the worst. Did
you play us on it? Well,
I thought we were going to have
more fun with no, we got it.
Take it out of this deal.
I didn't think you're going to get yeah,
totally devastated. Told me. Yeah.
Yeah,
that's all right. Call her. Hey. Hi.
So I just, I have mom and dad here. I
just did the, uh, the game we did and
mom was in tears. She was not
amused. No idea. I was devastated.
She was so upset by it.
Basically,
the first year were they born or stir fry
and have sex with a stranger is a pass
around four times a day.
Call me because you'd have like city
grams of cocaine and they give you an idea
at one line is, I don't know what
ever. So you have like 43 a day.
You went to jail.
I'll be naked in the streets.
We don't give giving you shit for him.
He said,
Oh know only from the stores and stuff.
But you went in people's houses
and think that his teams, yeah,
I mean all I'm doing is crying.
She mom was crying and I said, me,
I can't believe this is my daughter,
is it? But is in the past month? Yeah.
I told him was in the past, but she
was just super effective is I told him,
I said, you know what, she needs to
learn from this and this is never, ever,
ever judge anybody.
Yeah. You can't judge anybody
because you were a prostitute.
I never hear judging and I,
and I'm sitting there thinking I'm
spending 18,000 in the current tuition.
No. How you guys know it's a joke, right?
No,
of course.
Now I know there's torture as do
the this big time on this one.
Yeah. Big Time. There was really good
you think?
What did you think dad?
Dad was like, and he seemed to in kind
of shock the one that he was like,
I just refused to believe it was when,
uh,
you said you did one porno back in
college. He was like, I can't, he says,
I can believe that.
But he did believe that you broke
into people's houses and boss
and he did believe totally. They
do have sex with this today. Yeah,
he did believe you had sex with four guys.
He did.
Why was it that roof and Maria, do
you remember what his mom saying? Oh,
I remember that. I didn't
even know. I remember,
we remember one hotel that we were there.
Has it pulled in the roots?
Do you remember that Maria? Yeah. Okay.
And you went to the hotel that had a in
the room around, in the roof. On the roof.
We went with hotel. Then you got a lot
of hotels out there. I was with us.
And you said,
I'm gonna go and lay in the pool.
I'm looking back and get to
the base there. You haven't
have sites. Don't tell me.
That was great.
They have wanted to stay in this picking
up because I took it like you have a
great day with a pool and the
sun and they tend to be that.
It wasn't man walking by and I don't know
what did they pay you for this or what?
Oh my God. No, no, no.
This is all made up.
I can believe her. I mean,
he made me get out. Yeah.
Saturday.
I actually cut it short.
I didn't play the whole thing because
I saw how upset you were getting.
No, no, no, you're not. I tried to put
it behind and said, and five it comes in.
One of he uses,
I think of Mighty Asic.
Yeah. He was like, Nice.
Aw, that's sweet. Well, I promise you
guys, it was all made up. We just did it.
Yep. Well, you succeeded in that.
I lost 10 pounds in one minute.
Yeah. You didn't get a job.
Yeah. Good job, Maria.
Right. This is a 500%. This is that.
This is all Tom. He's doing please.
This is all my thing. I, I did this.
I totally do. You guys. All right.
It was all made up. Okay. Bye Bye.
Bye Bye [inaudible] guys. Bye.
Okay.
MMM.
That's a lady farting.
Oh,
but you know how you said, do
they ever, that's such a fart.
Can you make a song out of it?
So that lady farted, right? Yeah.
Oh,
and then,
uh,
a guy sent this in.
Okay.
Oh,
he's
got
to get beat.
Then he turns to the far end of the note.
[inaudible]
what do you think? That's my
kind of music. I love that music.
It's amazing. They can be
spiteful. Barrett's by babies.
Hurts.
Oh my God.
This or some shit because birds sing.
So with immune birds do sing.
There's this thing and they also
shit on you from 5,000 feet. Hey,
what do you guys think of this by the way?
Oh my God.
This is something that I thought you
might have something to say on. No.
All right.
Hey everybody. Welcome back this week
going to be talking to you about pronouns.
Sonos preferred pronouns or preferred
gender pronouns or PGPs, um,
whatever you call him.
Pronouns,
the things we use to refer to people in
the third person that are their names.
They're also often used as the linguistic
representation that people's gender
identities. So there are really
important, really, really,
really important.
Okay. You understand what
that this is or no? Yes. You
know, a gender Pronoun. Is He?
Him?
She,
her
like that. Okay. So I got,
um, you know, got it. Yeah.
All right.
The first and most important rule
regarding pronouns is to respect people's
pronouns. Always. There's
a rule number two,
always ask,
don't assume it's far better to ask you
someone's Pronoun is just be like, hey,
hi. How are you? What's your name? What's
Your Pronoun? Not every dealer. Hey,
just want her to confirm what's, what's
your pronoun? It's so much better to do.
Most people are really like just pleased
when someone asks about them cause it
can feel very welcoming and accepting.
Um, when other people do that,
especially when you're newly coming
out. Um, worst case I want to be,
there are a lot of pronouns out there,
like huge amount.
So this is where the things have
changed recently. I, first of all,
I hear you laughing.
So the different,
this is going to be now what people want
to be referred to as like slowly and
slowly adding, Huh? Oh I go by they them.
Well was the two most
common ones are he and she,
she has is traditionally considered a
male pronoun and she is traditionally
considered a female pronoun.
However,
it's important to note that some people
use he or she but did not identify as
male or female.
So if someone says,
oh my parent is he, you can't just
assume that they're male or you know,
if they say,
sure,
what are you laughing
at? Funny, funny video.
How can you talk about it? Here
is not a male I am assuming. Yeah,
that's all I say.
She but I call him a hit.
So basically it's a he because he
was born male but now he has it.
Well this is more about you're
talking about um, sex organs.
This is gender identity.
So like we're not,
but if for some people the gender
identity spectrum is very wide.
When I want to understand this,
like if I talk about you and I say hey,
there are actually,
I don't mean he but it is because you
don't describe yourself as a male.
Right, right, right, right. Can I see war?
You can't assume that there are female.
Um, so if you were to say like I prefer,
I prefer like masculine
pronouns are male pronouns.
It sort of implying that
everyone else who uses he
uses,
you know,
it is male or that like everyone
has identified as male uses heat,
which is not also not
necessarily the case.
So it's better to just say I
prefer he'd be done with it, um,
or she could be done with it.
It gets better.
Um, now. So then they're
also gender neutral pronouns,
gender neutral pronouns can be used for
anybody of any gender and they have no
gendered meanings attached to them
at all, which is super cool. Um,
and there are so many of them.
The most commonly used is they,
they have traditionally plural,
but we already used in the singular
form to like maintain people's anonymity
here. Like if you just don't know what
their gender is, you'll be like, oh,
I was talking to a student and they
told me Blah Blah, blah. Totally normal.
So you can use it for specific people as
well. And a lot of people prefer they,
how did you feel about in your office
somebody having a gender identity thing
and saying, I like to be referred
to as day, then that work.
I mean if I have normally called
people by their name, right,
but if you're referring to somebody
and they have a gender identity,
like preference,
but Pronoun Preferences,
I would still refer to that other person
by their name rather than they them.
So if I'm in an office and they're
talking about Bob or Bobby,
I would not say they them.
I would say Bob or Bobby
next.
Most common I've seen as z.
Z can be spelled a bunch of different
ways and it can be declined,
but in bigger ways it's like
declension lake. So like he, him,
his and then Z. Z. He are here.
That z Zim Zur.
Yeah, Darryl was, there are
a lot of options with z.
So if someone says I prefer Z,
ask them what spelling
and if they can use it,
can they use that in the office?
Well, I think as a neuroma one,
I think Czi I think it was it. Okay.
But that's what you think of him.
That he's telling you how people use it.
So what is z means?
Z is a pronoun. That is what? That is.
Gender neutral. So you're not
identifying with either gender.
Oh,
you know, is your mind blown or no?
Well, I mean I think I hear women.
Yeah, that's for real. I hear you.
I hear, I hear women often say,
you guys right. Okay.
Referring to they use Z,
I'm referring to a group of other women.
Right, right. Okay. So I think that,
you know, the, who's responsibility is it?
Is it the responsibility of the
minority or the majority and which,
that's an interesting, it's an interesting
question. Okay. And the question is,
if you get closer to the
mic, I think that, you know,
for me the challenge is, and it
also have, you can raise the arm,
the arm. No, not from
there. Not from there.
Okay,
awesome.
You know,
believe that there should be some
deference to seniority and tradition.
Okay.
So if you have somebody who's 70 years
old who was raised in an environment
where this is the way,
as long as he's not,
as long as he's not overly disrespectful
or trying to be disrespectful. Right.
But he's traditional and his commentary,
I don't think it's up to him to modify
his behavior in order to make the new
minority Hamby I, I totally see what
you're saying there. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just don't,
I mean,
I will say I do prefer these
him Zur as a pronoun for myself.
Tell me
I never heard that.
Z.
Yeah. Yeah. I've never heard this
for real. I've never heard it.
Z means you don't have it yet.
So Z is,
is how you'd say he,
if somebody was like, oh, or
she, for somebody that goes,
I'm not he or she, um, z.
So you areZ ,
right?
So you'd say Zee said z one at a coke.
I get the dose or Zim over there. Oh my
God. This is not for real though. Yeah.
This is for real.
I'm glad it
one last too long because this is as
crazy as it comes. Now, if you are a toZ
and Christina is a psyllidZ or is it she,
she uh,
she's more on the,
on the female gender spectrum.
Yeah. So, so far still,
sometimes she goes by,
they them.
So you had in z?
Yeah. Let, let me, let me, cause
both of you speak Spanish. No,
but I want to know Amy.
Where's sure. Okay. The baby is a hero.
The baby's on z right now.
We're trying not to place too many
gender identity issues like on him.
So we're still, it is a boy. I know. So
I know. I'm trying to dial that back.
So you have to say on Z.
Yeah.
All right.
Since both of you speak Spanish,
which is a mask in the feminine language,
unlike English,
which has a lot of adjectives
or verbs or whatever,
there are adjectives that are gender
neutral. Gender neutral. Yeah.
How does this translate
into other languages,
which are very much like
French or Spanish or Italian,
which you're very much
a masculine feminine.
That's a good question. I mean, I
don't have the answer, you know,
I don't know what the answer is.
Spanish to you because I will
know what to call you. Um,
uh, Z does moving,
but as yes,
see it,
Christina,
Eh, oh yeah. I would
just, instead of saying a,
I would say if he Stena like he
was saying and, and, and see.
Oh, how about uh,
[inaudible] if diving there.
It sounds feminine.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
it's good.
Z
you will know. Say you're making
it. It's very interesting.
It's interesting stuff. Any money you will
make it French or rice. Oh my goodness.
Yeah.
So, so can I, can I bring up a question
here that I have on my mind? Uh, you can.
Okay. You know, there's
been a lot of this LBG,
LBGT,
whatever it's called.
So the issue is like going
to the bathroom. Okay.
Yeah, that's a popular topic
on the show. Okay. Going to
the bathroom is, yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Now if you have a
transgender person who says,
I, I'm more, I want to use
the ladies' bathroom. Yeah.
Even though he has the physical
characteristics of a male. Right.
How are the, when he goes into a
woman's, they, you stalls on the women's.
So it's a little bit different. But
if, if the guy gets out of a stall,
how are the women going to know he's
transgender and not some guy who was in
there looking for a peak?
Well,
I mean transgender people don't
look like a guy looking for a peak.
No, but how do they know that? Well,
what do you mean? How did they know that?
Why did he is not really how,
but that seems to not be an issue.
Like it's, it's the issue of people
like saying it, but it's not.
But what I'm saying,
I understand his question now.
I don't think somebody is not
really just gender. Right.
I use the skews of it. Their agenda
right there is as a transgender. Right.
But it really is a male. Right.
He can go into the ladies room.
What I'm saying is I
understand that and what I,
what I'm saying is as of now,
yeah, that's not an issue because,
no, it's not, it's not an issue because,
because we have transgender people
using restrooms all the time now.
Yeah.
And the occurrences that you're speaking
of are obviously an anomaly because,
well, they have, it's gone. It has an
APP, you know, we act as an API yet,
but it's I rapists. But I mean
those are anomalies. Yeah.
So you can't just say,
well the one guy who was
posing as it was faking,
so therefore all the other transgender
people who are transgender,
I mean you're talking about like, so
the one in a thousand thing needs to be,
so I think [inaudible] are we going
to go to rather than a for the future
multisectoral Unisex restrooms.
Yeah, I think we are. Yeah.
That's where I think it's all going.
We're going to a bigger bathrooms. Yeah,
but the issue you bring up,
I don't think it's an issue.
You don't think it's an issue?
I mean, it's not an issue.
It's an issue of the imagination,
but it's not an actual real world issue
because we do have transgender people
using restrooms. Yeah. Using the
opposite sex restroom. I have never seen,
most people just want to relieve
themselves. I haven't seen that yet.
But it's happening all the time. You
don't even know it. Shut it down.
How do we do not,
well,
we haven't had any people
that look male in the grocery.
I'm wanting to know the difference.
The other guy,
you can be transgender and still dress,
get you as a male and you're,
and you're, and you're inside. You're a
female. No, that's, that's not really,
that's the work that way.
No. No. Okay. All right.
Okay. Yeah, I think the
issue is not an issue.
The issue is econ bullying because there
is so much going on lately and every
sense that it could be a great business
says, okay, this is my chance. No,
it could happen. I'm not
saying it couldn't, but I also
think that like, it's like
the rapist is still gonna rape.
Whether or not we have this,
he doesn't need to be. Yeah. This
issue is actually completely different.
Prophets are rapist.
No, no. Or even a paper.
It's like they're going to do
that regardless of the rule.
Most people want to just go to the
bathroom in comfort and just feel feeling.
I can appreciate that more than anyone.
I know you can. I know you can. Um,
wanted to show you this now that we
got off of that serious topic, um,
uh,
this apparently this guy made this and
there's an argument that it's the longest
fart ever. Um, yeah, this one.
Oh, there's an argument whether, yeah,
tell me if you think it's real
because you can see him breathing.
You can hear the room tone audio.
He's got a microphone there.
The bed.
I know
the guys had a lot of parts
consistent.
Yeah.
Great.
I think that when you have
a real fart like that,
it's,
the tone is to consistent and almost
like as a mechanical device further for
awhile because you have this consistent
tone and as you have pressure released
in your large bowel, okay. It's not
going to be completely consistent. So,
but it doesn't sound completely
consistent. It goes, well
there's a longer, I know,
but there's a long section in there that
there that it sounds like it was just
the, the frequency didn't really change
that much. I have had long farms.
Yeah. You have really long
for it. Well, she does. Oh,
scream from the bedroom. I'm
in the bathroom. Oh my God.
I can't believe how long I know what,
he's a long prayer. Unfortunately.
Sound comfortable.
There's no way you can last that
long and it still keep going. Yeah,
I don't agree.
That doesn't mean that it made up.
I can pretend to do anything of this song.
Okay.
This is Charla.
Mommy,
John Doe Music.
I know mom's told you both got done.
Yeah.
So you
hear it.
I like it right
here.
All right,
well someone else did it.
Matthew Miller made the song for the last
time you were on the show like a long
time ago. Cause it's, it's good.
It's really good.
There's a few for dad.
This chart, this chart would know about
the Orlando airport. She know that story.
Good luck.
You know, I, I think, I think
I told her at the time. Yeah.
But I took in the terror
and the Orlando right dump.
They kind of went through
my pants and she knows.
Do you know about that one though?
It went through his pants and he
couldn't get it off. So he flew with,
got got on the pants.
That was it.
I had no choice.
Yeah. Well. And you go to
the bathroom before you go?
No, I, I raced into the men's room there,
but I just didn't make it in time.
So I had to ditch my underwear in,
in the or with Gacaca and your
pants and get in the plane.
I wiped it off as best I could.
Okay. Ah, flush four or five times.
Went through a whole roll of toilet paper,
try to clean things up.
But in the end I had spots,
stains and my tracking my ass.
Oh no underwear. And I had
to fly to Arizona. I Europe,
Orlando to Arizona in Orlando
to Arizona. So, you know,
there's little cock out in that seat,
which makes you think about how many
seats have got, got what he's eating.
Told me. Because you can
not have Catholic. No, it's
just, you know, as you're,
you're the cook.
Okay.
So some of your food maybe because if I'm
the cook more reason not to have them,
I don't go,
oh that was,
we went from
but eight fast this morning. Yeah. But
eight cause we went to Pete's cafe. Yeah,
you have it.
Mafia would have coffee.
We're walking back and
they love to tell him.
He started walking with the two legs.
Yeah,
next to each other and it deleted
a little penguin stuffed. Nope.
First we're going and he was walking
in Berlin as load my back hurts,
my neck hurts. We sit down,
we got the coffee, come back.
[inaudible] speeding little,
you know,
like a little 87 year old mom that
doesn't want to get killed. Yeah.
And he's being good job. Good job. I
said, oh, it's coming up. It's coming up.
I have to do it. Good. I have to make
it. It'll be okay because it's a muffin.
Oh No, no, actually it's, it triggers
when you eat, it triggers your about,
oh, tell him, tell him what almost
happened this morning. My God,
he almost got killed.
This is not funny at all.
That Kenny light were coming back
from the template. [inaudible]
yeah, we are crossing the
street. The light is green
and it's feeling as you know,
and as we're closing, he's on the left.
I'm on the right. A guy decided to come.
How do you say making a
lefthand turn into Mercedes.
And of course he was looking at his phone.
Yeah.
They ain't look at and glows from hitting
your father then you had the right
away. Oh yeah, we had the
white thing. Yeah. Oh yeah.
He's looking at his phone was
what'd you do? Well I jumped back,
almost spilled the coffee,
you know,
and it would say he came
within three feet of madness.
Listen that and what surprises me?
I said don't at least I would roll
down my windows. I'm so sorry.
The guy went like this. Like
you know you're safe. Yeah.
Yeah. That was a skewed. Yeah.
Why?
Okay.
Yeah.
Can we get one new question?
I've been half.
This is the cold shoulder
related to mostly farts.
Yeah. You know, I do see
mostly far it's got guy. Um,
so that is not, we cannot be funny
and this with heart. No, no we,
we do sexual stuff too,
but I'm leaving that out cause you're here
a my part of enjoying life.
Yeah.
It's to make the most out
of everything that you do,
that you see lying down in the Serengeti
when they stake out their territory.
You know, they're sad. It's what I do.
Anytime I start blowing farts, you know,
30 minutes later I'll be dropping one in.
Did you just,
did you just turn your hand?
This was a real squirter drop my load.
Just chill and take it down.
He's the Oprah of shitting.
Absolutely. Kind of the doctor.
Eyes of the radio network.
You know the wipes people use to clean
like countertops, industrial strength.
Always use the handicap stall or to hold
your keys together when you're walking
down stairs.
The cheeks on stay close.
That's good.
See,
these are all little tidbits of
advice said I've helped Tommy's view
listenerships over the years and
they've got some good feedback on this.
Definitely.
Oh yeah.
Part of enjoying life to
make the most out of it.
Uh, but yeah, there's a
lot of top dog songs. Um,
and then, uh, you know what,
one of my favorite thing is,
is that the first time you guys ever like
it was Weston was born and I went down
there and you had guy,
you guys argued it was the funniest thing.
I've never laughed so hard
and I recorded it on my phone.
I hear what you're doing here. I
never get bored with, you know,
I'll give you and said that. What did
you tell me? You called me and said,
you know,
it's funny.
It's a big thing and they get so bored
with you was that nick doesn't get them
focused on doing that conversation.
Yeah,
but you're automatically
included in my list.
Right? I told you that other times
you don't get it. No, you didn't.
Well,
what am I here
ever been bored with you? Well, you
don't have a choice. You live with me.
If you're a boy,
he's willing to look at me and said,
you need to wear a necklace today.
Oh
does this one to,
one of the things we've talked about on
our show is I tell our listeners how you
gave me great advice on how to wipe you.
Remember when I called you and I was like,
I just keep wiping and you told me maybe
you're wiping too hard and you're going
in, right? Yes, I do remember
that. And what'd you tell me?
Do you need to wipe down,
wipe down,
and also not push in,
right.
Not to push in because it
just drives him more in, yeah.
Yeah.
What is your profession
you cut out to be discussing? No,
I just hope this give you for,
I can just do this.
Your daughter, your wife. Well for sure.
Okay.
So now what happened?
Now if you wiped too hard, like I used
to get dingleberry's well not just that,
but you, you can be pushing into
your bottle. That's right. Right.
And that's why it was always
brown, right time. Right, exactly.
And then there was the booger incident,
which mom also was there for.
Yeah, it was great. Yesterday. What?
What did you do in the elevator?
Put a big booger on the
number one a button.
So this way I get spreading germs out of
my nose. All the residents of the hotel.
Why would you do that? It's fun. It's fun.
What's that?
What do think is disgusting?
They been the same.
I'm recording it. Yeah.
So do people know that your
father is absolutely disgusting?
I don't think this is funny
what it's. You know what he did right?
Did she? No. No, no. Don't tell her.
Don't tell me
you said it.
I didn't die when I cleaned it off.
I didn't quit.
That's the funny.
Have you ever,
I don't see no one is called is a closet.
Oh Man. I laughed so hard
at that. You liked that one.
Nobody. Yeah, that was great.
That was good one.
Then you are disgusting diarrhea.
And you know what I noticed where I
actually enjoy being discussing. He does.
He does. And that's what
he, the story of nobody.
Everybody gets bored. He
messaged you. Yeah. He keeps
repeating until today. Yeah.
And I keep reminding that I exist.
Yeah.
The baby. Yes. Obvious I do too. Yeah.
They, he does enjoy being discussing.
He does. When, when we were,
uh, we went to Maine together.
Oh, that was so much fun.
He shit his pants there
and he told me the story.
It's because he went in the handicap
stall and it was too far away.
It was good. Yesterday. I didn't
make it and I was, you know,
it was just ugly.
I had to go and you know,
I misread the sign and the hotel. Yeah.
And they had to go down the stairs and I,
I was squeezing the cheeks
going down the stairs. Yeah.
And then went into one of these
places, you know, where the, you know,
you're rushing in,
but it's one of these handicap stalls.
It's an extra five feet
before you get to the, yeah.
And it's five feet too far.
Five feet too far.
Okay.
True Story.
Can they live [inaudible] works
in a serious business. Yeah.
He enjoys being in a party,
whatever this thing is called. Yeah.
And talk about his files,
shitting his pants. What
is newco thing? Elevator.
It's like having a two year old.
Guess what I did.
It's the most embarrassing thing possible
for an adult. Is your husband. Oh,
I'm not sure for how long
you think take getting that toilet for
$20,000. If he wants to know. Oh my God.
All right. Well this is
really fun. Um, I think, uh,
later I'll try to get you to
read some copy for us, some
advertisements, okay. Oh,
sure. Okay. Sure. I like that. Okay. And
that'll be fun. Okay. Buddy does in both.
There's no force in those.
Okay. All right. I love you.
Okay.
Jeans
calm.
Uh,
oh.